[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos de visual polític
durante las últimas semanas bolivia ha
vivido toda una vorágine de
acontecimientos unas elecciones un
fraude electoral una revolución civil y
finalmente lo que parecía imposible
la caída de evo morales está que vamos a
ver es la historia de como evo morales
pasó de tener todo el poder a renunciar
a la presidencia y está incluso en busca
y captura- atentos
el día 20 de octubre de 2019 se
celebraron en este país elecciones
generales desde esa misma noche tras
presentarse en los resultados la paz
social estalló por los aires desde
entonces las protestas y manifestaciones
tanto de la oposición como también de
los partidarios del oficialismo de los
partidarios de evo morales se han
sucedido sin descanso en las principales
ciudades del país en lo que algunos ya
califican como la primavera boliviana el
aeropuerto de la paz convertido en campo
de batalla una alcaldía devorada por
llamas y gases lacrimógenos en los
innumerables puntos de bloqueo
instalados a lo largo del país la
situación está tan tensa que incluso se
ha producido un motín policial policía
se amotinan contra evo morales- que
denuncia a golpe de estado en marcha la
primera en rebelarse fue la unidad
táctica de operaciones policiales de la
ciudad central de cochabamba y poco
después se amotinaron los comandos de
otras ciudades todo esto tiene que ver
con algo que ya os dijimos aquí en
visual político que podría ocurrir
como evo morales- se había enamorado del
poder como se había saltado la legalidad
vigente' para poder volver a presentarse
y como todo apuntaba a que harían lo
posible y lo imposible por mantenerse en
el poder
[Aplausos]
[Música]
aunque eso supusiera seguir la
estrategia de pucherazos que ha
mantenido en el poder a personajes tan
ilustres como nicolás maduró daniel
ortega o juan orlando hernández el poder
a toda costa pues amigos eso es
exactamente lo que sucedió pero dicho
esto veamos qué diantres ha pasado
exactamente en bolivia
[Música]
una historia anunciada
toda esta historia comenzó el 21 de
febrero de 2016
ese día el 51% de los bolivianos rechazó
en referéndum la modificación del
artículo 168 de la constitución de la
propia constitución aprobada a
instancias del propio evo morales que
prohibía la reelección por más de un
mandato de una forma clara clarísima el
periodo de mandato de la presidenta o
del presidente y de la vicepresidenta o
del vicepresidente del estado es de 5
años y pueden ser reelectas o reelectos
por una sola vez de manera continua
artículo 168 de la constitución de
bolivia ante esta situación con una
constitución que tú mismo has aprobado y
que resulta tan clara y además con un
referéndum donde el pueblo te ha dicho
que no lo normal es que tú dijeras vale
respeto las normas que ese presente otro
candidato por mi partido estamos de
acuerdo no al menos eso es lo que ocurre
en todo país con un mínimo estado de
derecho pues amigos
evo no iba a pasar por ahí dejar
ni de broma
y ocurrió lo que ocurre en todos los
países donde un gobierno ccoo para todas
las instituciones que no trabajan por el
interés general sino por el de ese
gobierno
de esta forma en 2017 el tribunal
constitucional plurinacional de bolivia
publicó la grotesca sentencia 00 84
2017 por la que se declararon
inconstitucionales artículos de la
propia constitución entre ellos por
supuesto el artículo 168 de tal forma
que se abría paso a la reelección
indefinida que como es posible esto
bienvenidos a la bolivia de evo morales
el caso es que esta controvertida
decisión del tribunal constitucional
supuso un enorme palo para el estado de
derecho en bolivia al final daba igual
lo que dijese la constitución o lo que
votaran los propios bolivianos lo único
lo único que contaba era el deseo de evo
morales y ante esa situación una gran
parte de la sociedad boliviana se echó a
la calle para protestar bajo el grito de
bolivia dijo no
[Música]
pero os hago otra pregunta pensáis que
esto el efecto algo a evo morales que
quizás le hizo reconducir su posición
para tratar de llegar a un entendimiento
con la mayoría de la sociedad boliviana
asia había votado que no a la reelección
pues evidentemente no lo ha dejado claro
que lo que él quiere es el poder a toda
costa por eso
[Música]
por un proyecto político de la vibración
por un programa de gobierno del pueblo
también para la liberación pero también
para desarrollarnos
pero amigos en ese momento sí que
empezaron a cambiar algunas cosas el
gobierno había perdido el referéndum
jugando limpio así que había que
asegurarse de que llegado el momento
nunca más se volviera a perder en las
urnas y sabéis que dicho y hecho desde
ese preciso momento empezaron a
producirse situaciones extrañas
anormales inauditas fijaos
[Música]
muchos vocales y funcionarios del
tribunal supremo electoral renunciaron
ante las fortísimas presiones del
gobierno el padrón electoral creció de
forma digamos sospechosa entre 2005 y
2019 un 190 por ciento un crecimiento
espectacular que evidentemente no guarda
ninguna correlación con el crecimiento
de la población durante el mismo periodo
de tiempo y las cosas han ido a peor a
medida que se fueron acercando a las
elecciones
este pueblo que está aquí en las calles
está pidiendo que es el respeto que este
tribunal supremo electoral denuncie
porque ellos no han respetado el 21 efe
no tenemos confianza que en las
elecciones vanas respetados
el partido oficialista el más el
movimiento al socialismo no se ha
cortado un pelo en usar los medios del
estado para hacer campaña sin que por
supuesto las autoridades electorales
dijeran absolutamente nada estas
autoridades estaban muy ocupadas
censurando las encuestas independientes
que no daban como ganador a evo morales
ese fue el caso por ejemplo de las
encuestas elaboradas por la universidad
mayor de san andrés
[Música]
que porque quería el gobierno censurar
encuestas pensando si vais a cometer un
pucherazo tendrás que asegurarte de que
no sea muy escandaloso no os parece
[Música]
incluso la única empresa autorizada para
realizar el conteo rápido de votos el
día de las elecciones fue mi agencia una
empresa con menos de un año de vida
vamos lo más normal del mundo darle el
control del proceso electoral a una
empresa recién creada y sin experiencia
si no se lo habéis entendido
perfectamente el camino hacia el fraude
electoral estaba servido y por supuesto
el camino llegó a su destino
amigos queréis saber como evo morales-
robó las elecciones os atentos
[Música]
si el tribunal supremo electoral
a mejorar
esa ley que habilita
el binomio mucho ilegal e
inconstitucional de álvaro garcía linera
y evaporar eso
el gran robo
el tribunal supremo electoral la máxima
autoridad electoral de bolivia se
comprometió a entregar el cien por cien
del conteo rápido de resultados a las
ocho de la noche del mismo día de los
comicios pues sabéis lo que ocurrió que
llegada la hora el tribunal electoral
entregó los resultados al 83% del
recuento no la totalidad y la
transmisión de resultados electorales
quedó suspendida sin ningún aviso ni
aclaración
en este momento amigos los resultados
preliminares marcaban una tendencia
clara en la votación evo morales- ganaba
en la primera vuelta con un 45 28 por
ciento sobre carlos meza el principal
candidato opositor que obtenía este un
38 16 por ciento existía por tanto una
diferencia de 7,12 puntos entre ambos
candidatos lo que conforme al artículo
167 de la constitución obligaba a
celebrar una segunda vuelta
a favor y hasta la mira detrás de todo
el mundo como un país modelo como todo
pueden aportar
[Aplausos]
la constitución de bolivia en su
artículo 167 determina que será
declarado presidente el candidato que
supere el 50 por ciento de los votos o
que superando el 40 por ciento le saque
10 puntos de diferencia al segundo
candidato más votado si no se cumplen
esas condiciones entonces se tiene que
celebrar una segunda vuelta una segunda
vuelta en la que dados los resultados la
victoria de evo morales no estaban ni
mucho menos asegurada
sin embargo amigos ya os hemos dicho
antes que no estaba dispuesto a perder
el poder y tenía un plan al día
siguiente y tras más de 17 horas
suspendidas sin ninguna explicación la
transmisión rápida de resultados
preliminares de un salto en el
escrutinio del 83 al 95 por ciento para
volver a quedar suspendida hasta que
finalmente 55 días después se alcanzó el
100% del escrutinio y sorpresa los
resultados serán de repente muy
diferentes ya no había segunda vuelta
evo superaba los 10 puntos de diferencia
respecto a su rival y ahí ahí estalló
todo
miles y miles de ciudadanos comenzaron a
concentrarse frente al tribunal
electoral y la sospecha de fraude corrió
por todas las esquinas ningún sondeo
ninguna medición ni tampoco ningún
programa estadístico habían previsto
semejante desviación de voto una
desviación en la parte final del
recuento que se produjo además de una
forma totalmente opaca y en medio de
grandes irregularidades en el proceso de
recuento
porque estamos viviendo defectos
nuestros derechos
las cosas los zonales papás sean izadas
con los manudos manudos son unos años
de esta forma es como se pusieron en
marcha protestas a lo largo y ancho de
todo el país protestas que demandaban
fundamentalmente una cosa elecciones
limpias y por supuesto tal y como os
podéis imaginar la primera reacción del
gobierno fue tratar de ahogar las
protestas mediante la represión de los
cuerpos de seguridad del estado y no
sólo eso lejos de buscar una salida al
problema lo que hizo evo fue denunciar
un presunto golpe de estado contra él
contra el un presidente que no ha dudado
en saltarse su propia constitución y
poner a todas las instituciones del
estado a su servicio personal
[Música]
ahora bien llegados a este punto puede
que alguno de vosotros estará pensando
ha sido tan claro el pucherazo el fraude
el atraco electoral pues lo cierto es
que todo apunta a que sí
[Música]
en esto hay una coincidencia
prácticamente total entre los actores
independientes por ejemplo las
organizaciones internacionales que
actuaron como observadoras en las
elecciones como es el caso de la unión
europea o la organización de estados
americanos la oea han recomendado
celebrar una segunda vuelta porque
simplemente fundado oficial no puede ser
aceptado como bueno toda elección debe
regirse por los principios de certeza
legalidad transparencia equidad
independencia e imparcialidad la misión
pudo constatar que varios de estos
principios han sido vulnerados por
distintas causas a lo largo de este
proceso electoral informe de los
observadores de la organización de
estados américanos y aquí no queda todo
aún hay más por su parte miembros de la
sociedad civil han puesto sobre la mesa
un montón de irregularidades es el caso
por ejemplo del ingeniero de sistemas
informáticos edgar villegas que junto a
un equipo de profesionales se han
dedicado a comparar las tablas del
cómputo oficial con las de la
transmisión de resultados
i
la conclusión la conclusión es que el
proceso ha estado lleno de trampas como
por ejemplo la eliminación de mesas de
sufragios para favorecer al más al
partido de evo morales- y aún más fijaos
la auditoría oficial calificó como
viciadas de nulidad a las elecciones y
carlos meza exigió nuevos comicios la
empresa contratada por el tribunal
supremo electoral entregó un informe en
el que afirma que no puede dar fe de la
integridad de los resultados de las
elecciones presidenciales del 20 de
octubre pasado ya lo veis es que ni
siquiera la misma empresa contratada por
el tribunal electoral que le ha
permitido todo a evo se atreve a validar
los resultados el fraude parece del
libro y finalmente el informe preliminar
de la organización de estados américanos
ha ido en la misma línea el fraude el
engaño el timo la burla a la voluntad
popular fue evidente evo morales- quiso
convertirse en todo un caudillo al mejor
estilo de sus socios nicolás maduro o
daniel ortega que como todos sabéis son
unos auténticos expertos en saltarse el
proceso democrático
[Música]
lo que debo hacer con pasar hoy en día
está pasando en venezuela no queremos
pasar nada
una válida libre una válida negra con
soberanía para nuestros hijos para el
futuro de nuestros hijos amigos quien
haya seguido la actualidad política de
bolivia seguro seguro que tiene una cosa
clara evo morales y va a tratar de
perpetuarse en el poder contra viento y
marea sin embargo las protestas en la
calle que no querían ver a evo
convertido en un nuevo nicolás maduro y
la chapucera y escandalosa forma en la
que se intentó perpetrar el robo
electoral hizo que el tiro le saliese
por la culata la policía comenzó a
motivarse para no tener que cumplir con
las órdenes de represión del gobierno y
eso junto a las masivas protestas que se
estaban produciendo en el país llevó a
evo a anunciar la convocatoria de nuevas
elecciones convocar a nuevas elecciones
nacionales que mediante el voto permitan
al pueblo boliviano elegir
democráticamente a sus nuevas
autoridades
[Música]
pero claro va a organizar y presentarse
a las elecciones la misma persona el
mismo presidente que han cometido el
fraude qué credibilidad puede tener ese
proceso la mera repetición de elecciones
ya no era suficiente la calle la
oposición los medios independientes
todas las fuerzas ajenas almas pasaron a
exigir la dimisión del presidente y
finalmente el ejército hizo lo mismo
[Música]
lo que es la mejor decisión que ha
tomado
[Música]
de hecho esa fue la gota que colmó el
vaso sin la calle sin la policía y sin
el ejercito evo morales se vio obligado
a presentar su dimisión y renunciar a la
presidencia de bolivia una decisión que
pilló a la comunidad internacional
totalmente desprevenida sorpresa por la
renuncia de evo morales tras 14 años
como presidente de bolivia morales pidió
a los líderes opositores a los que
acusan de instar un golpe de estado para
echarle del poder que no maltraten a los
bolivianos y les dejen de patear evo
morales- denuncia que la policía lo
busca para detenerlo luego de presentar
dimisión
esperad un momento porque por si esto
fuera poco mientras estábamos preparando
este vídeo evo morales- de nuevo ha dado
la sorpresa de evo morales viaja hacia
méxico en un avión del gobierno de lópez
obrador en visual político seguiremos de
cerca los acontecimientos ahora
continuamos con el vídeo vale puede que
el procedimiento no haya sido el mejor
pero estaba en juego la democracia
boliviana evo se tenía que haber
marchado pero se emborrachó de poder y
quiso hacer de bolivia su cortijo claro
que aquí no termina todo
bolivia se enfrenta ahora no sólo un
conflicto institucional profundo sino
también a importantes desequilibrios
económicos los últimos años de evo han
sido malos muy malos y el futuro no está
ni mucho menos claro que el país
necesita un cambio de rumbo total pero
de todo esto hablaremos en un próximo
vídeo ahora ahora turno para ti
crees que la salida de vos será buena
para bolivia déjanos tus respuestas en
los comentarios y también en esta
encuesta si este vídeo se resulta
interesante no dudéis darle a like y una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Aplausos]
no queremos ser pasar hoy en día está
pasando en venezuela no queremos pasar
una pasada en cuba
tenemos una bolivia libre una bobina
negra con soberanía para nuestros tipos
para el futuro de nuestros hijos